everybody walk by can I take a picture
with all of you best compliment hey can
we all take a picture together also when
they come and they like they give the
camera to one person hey can you take a
picture of me in
you're just kind of like okay I perform
too remember like you know keep adding
you know just keep at it you're good too
you can't keep working yeah that's the
one I hate yeah they come out they see
two people and they go oh my God they
were like oh yeah we liked you too
Patrice O'Neal had the funniest thing
about that ever because he used to you
know be back in New York back in Boston
and very early on he was the first one
of us to key into the you know getting
the you were good too one night if you
know anything about Patrice he was a
world-class ball buster yeah
and if you didn't understand why he was
coming at you the way he was you could
be very offended really quick one time a
guy gave Patrice to you too and tried to
do the what is that weird handshake
where it's not a proper handshake but
we're gonna we're gonna clasp hands let
you ever have somebody go and Shake Your
Hands they do this and it's like what
like we're holding hands gonna run
together for a minute
so
the the YouTube but he wanted to be
ready I'm Patrice get the hello
laughs
this whacked this guy to
where he pulled it and was stunned and
walked away Patrice said some more
Choice words but man it was the funniest
you two comeback